At this point, we’ve covered a lot of the
basics when it comes to how things move.
But we’ve mostly been focusing on only one
type of motion: translational motion,
which is when something moves through space,
but doesn’t rotate.
But rotational motion is also a thing -- and
an important one.
For example, the spin of a football -- both
the soccer and the non-soccer kind --
will affect the way it flies through the air.
But the physics of rotational motion isn’t
all that different from the physics of translational motion.
It still involves things like position, velocity,
and acceleration.
And many of the equations you use to describe
rotational motion will look really familiar to you.
But there are some important differences.
Like, instead of positions, there are angles.
And instead of points on a line, you follow
points along an arc.
And, there are times when rotational motion can explain things that sound impossible, but actually are true.
Like when a point on a spinning wheel,
is actually standing still.
So, the rules here are the same.
But rotational motion has what you might call
its own “circular logic.”
[Theme Music]
When it comes to translational motion, we tend to talk about position in terms of x and y.
Where is this object, horizontally?
And where is it vertically?
Those axes make sense, because we’re usually
tracking the object’s motion along those directions.
But for rotational motion, we really want
to know the object’s angle -- what we call theta.
Say we have a big disk with a dot painted
on it.
If we call the top of the disk our starting point, then when the dot is at the top, its angle would be zero.
And when the dot is at the left, its angle
would be 180 degrees -- half of a full circle.
But! Even though we’ve been measuring angles
using degrees until now, there’s another
unit that physicists use a lot, and it’ll
be the main one we’ll use in this episode and the next.
That unit is called the radian, and its name
comes from the fact that it’s based on the radius of a circle.
If you think back to basic geometry, you’ll
recall that the circumference of a circle
is just 2, times pi, times the circle’s
radius, right?
Radians describe angles by essentially telling you how much of that circumference is covered by a given angle.
So, 360 degrees -- which is a full circle’s
worth of angles -- would be 2 pi radians.
180 degrees -- or half a circle’s worth
of angles -- would be pi radians.
And to convert any number of degrees to radians, you just multiply the degrees times pi and divide by 180.
So now we know how to describe the angle of
something that’s rotating.
But what about the velocity of its rotation?
Well, we’ve already learned that plain old translational, or linear, velocity is a measure of an object’s change in position.
And in the same way, rotational velocity is
a measure of an object’s change in angle.
This is known as its angular velocity, and
is represented by the lowercase Greek letter, Omega.
which I want to point out looks a bit like a W, but itsn't a W.
And, as you might have guessed by now, angular
velocity is the derivative -- or, the rate
of change -- of angular displacement with
respect to time.
But we can also describe an object’s rotation
in terms of its tangential velocity.
This is the same type of velocity we used
when we talked about the physics of uniform circular motion.
Remember? With the key spinning around on
a string?
And that vomit-causing carnival ride?
In those cases, we described how, when an
object moves along a circular path, its velocity
is perpendicular to the radius of the circle,
in the direction of the motion.
And, when you think about it, any rigid object
rotating around a fixed axis is basically
a set of points, all moving along circular
paths.
So, at any given moment, each of those points
will have a tangential velocity that depends
on the path it moves through -- specifically,
the radius of that path.
In fact, its tangential velocity will be equal
to its angular velocity, times the radius.
It’s easy to see why this makes sense, if
you picture the spokes of a rotating wheel.
All of the points along each spoke have to
have the same angular velocity, because they
all cover the same angular distance in the
same amount of time.
But to get from, say, the right-hand side
of the circle to the bottom, the points on
the outside of the wheel will pass through
a much bigger arc -- covering more space,
basically -- than the points on the inside.
So, the farther that a point on the spoke
is from the center of the wheel, the greater
its tangential velocity has to be.
Like circular motion, rotational motion can
also be periodic -- when the rotation repeats
after a set amount of time, which is represented by a  capital T, also called The Period.
And the equations that describe periodic motion
are pretty much the same as the ones we used
for a single point moving along a circular
path:
So the frequency, or number of rotations that
happen every second, is equal to one, divided by the period.
But frequency and angular velocity are really
just two different ways of describing the
same thing -- they just use different units.
Frequency is measured in rotations -- or revolutions
-- per second, and angular velocity is measured
in radians per second.
And one revolution is equal to the circumference
of the circle: 2 pi radians.
So, in order to convert from frequency to
angular velocity, all you need to do is multiply
the frequency by 2 pi.
Now, there’s a special case when it comes
to the velocity of rotating objects, and that’s
what’s known as rolling without slipping.
This kind of motion shows up in real life
all the time.
It’s what happens to your car’s tires
when you drive down the street, as long as
you aren’t skidding -- which, let’s hope
you aren’t.
And it’s what a train’s wheels do as they
move along the track.
But it turns out that the translational velocity
at the bottom of the wheel is /super weird/.
Mainly, because at any given moment, the point at the bottom of the wheel doesn’t have a translational velocity.
In other words, it doesn’t actually move.
To figure out why, let’s experiment with
a bicycle wheel.
If you roll the wheel along the floor for
one full rotation, that means that the entire
circumference of the wheel will touch the
floor, one point at a time.
And the center of the wheel will move forward
by a distance that’s equal to the circumference
of the wheel -- aka its radius, times 2 pi.
And the time it took to move that distance
was equal to the period of the motion.
So, the translational velocity of the center
was equal to the radius, times the angular velocity.
Now, what about the top of the wheel?
It has the same translational velocity as
the center of the wheel, plus the tangential
velocity that comes from the wheel’s rotation.
Because, at the top of the wheel, the tangential
velocity is pointing in the direction the
wheel is rolling in.
And in the same way, the bottom of the wheel
has the same translational velocity as the
center of the wheel, minus the tangential
velocity that comes from the wheel’s rotation.
Because at the bottom of the wheel, the tangential velocity is pointing opposite to the direction the wheel is rolling in.
Here’s the weird part:
We just saw that the translational velocity of the wheel is equal to the radius, times the angular velocity.
And we know that in general, the magnitude
of tangential velocity is also equal to
the radius, times the angular velocity.
So, the top of the wheel will be moving exactly twice as fast as the center of the wheel, relative to the ground.
Because, to get its total velocity, you add
the translational velocity to the tangential velocity.
But the bottom of the wheel won’t be moving
at all … because its total velocity is
its translational velocity minus the tangential,
since they’re moving in opposite directions.
As a result, the total velocity at the bottom
of the wheel is zero.
Even though the wheel is clearly moving relative
to the ground.
But if you look at the wheel’s motion at
any given instant, you’ll see that whatever
point is at the bottom of the wheel can’t
be moving relative to the ground.
If it was moving relative to the ground
… that would be what we call slipping.
Like when a car is skidding on an icy ground:
The wheel isn’t turning, but the bottom
of the wheel is moving in relation to the
ground, because it’s sliding along on top of it.
But this wheel isn’t slipping -- its bottom has a total velocity of zero, because its velocities cancel out.
OK: I know I just blew your mind, so while
you put your head back together, I want to
talk about one more basic quality of rotational
motion: angular acceleration.
Based on what you already know about acceleration,
you can already guess that angular acceleration
is the derivative of angular velocity.
It’s represented by the lowercase Greek
letter alpha, and it describes how an object’s
angular velocity is changing over time.
And as an object rotates,  each point on it can actually accelerate in two different ways.
Radial acceleration is another term for what we’ve been calling centripetal acceleration up until now.
It’s the acceleration inward of any point
on our rotating object, and it’s equal to
the angular velocity, squared, times the radius.
But there’s also tangential acceleration,
which describes whether an individual point on a rotating object
is speeding up or slowing down.
So, like linear velocity, tangential acceleration
depends on the distance between the point
and the center of the object.
More specifically, it’s equal to the angular
acceleration, times the radius.
So you see, angular position, velocity, and
acceleration relate to each other in much
the same ways that linear position, velocity,
and acceleration do.
This allows us to talk about rotational motion
with terms and equations that are familiar
to us, once we’ve gotten the basics of translational
motion under our belts.
Next time, we’ll see how how the logic of rotational motion applies to another idea: momentum!
For now, you learned about the qualities of
rotational motion, including angular position,
angular velocity, periodic motion, and the
special case of rolling without slipping.
We also talked about angular acceleration,
as well as constant angular acceleration.
Crash Course Physics is produced in association
with PBS Digital Studios. You can head over
to their channel to check out amazing shows
like It's Okay to be Smart, Blank on Blank, and Shank's FX.
This episode of Crash Course was filmed in
the Doctor Cheryl C. Kinney Crash Course Studio
with the help of these amazing people and
our equally amazing graphics team is Thought Cafe.